for its fans fabric was a clubbing
institution music lovers regularly voted
it the best night club in the world
but now the council has voted to remove
its license because of an apparent drug
problem I think it's quite sad because I
think it's not the way to address the
problem of people dying from drugs and I
think fabric was known it did have good
resources to help people in the case of
you know things going wrong and I feel
like people just going to go to
different places now it's not going to
produce it
these people that died extremely sad but
I don't think you know they could be
taking drugs anywhere the club opened in
1999 the former Farringdon meat
warehouse became a hit with DJs the
world over but the council and police
raised concerns about drug use on the
premises after six deaths in four years
according to councillors there was a
culture of drug use with staff unable to
control it but for those in the
nightclub industry the decision raises
issues about how clubs are being
targeted in the war on drugs there is a
drug problem in this country we need to
confront that as a society you can't
blame the club that they end up in I
don't think there's any suggestion that
it was there was dealing in fabric I
think it's people smuggle small amounts
of drugs in and unless we strip search
people and have police dogs and the
doors are come I can't you do that
because I don't think that that chimes
repeat the New England I want to live in
that seals more like 1933 in Berlin to
me among the flowers this message from a
clubber called Gary highlights the wider
issue of nightclubs closing please don't
turn into a Tesco Metro he writes Gary
is of course joking but so often in the
last 10 years we've seen big city
nightclubs repurposed for different
commercial reasons here in Farrington
not far from fabric this building used
to be the legendary turn Mills nightclub
it's not a Tesco Metro but it's not far
off for DJ's like edy the world of uniq
live music is quickly shrinking a lot of
nightclubs are owned by especially the
bigger chains it's like listening to a
rather bland radio station during the
day you're gonna hear Shania Twain or
even Lee here Semisonic and I'm not
singling those artists out I'm just
saying those companies would rather push
the mainstream rather than champion the
underdog and more obscure electronic
music and that's what fabric is recent
figures show the number of nightclubs in
the UK has almost half in the last 10
years
fabrics owners say they'll fight against
their clubs joining the list but despite
its fame a damning verdict from the
authorities means for now the party's
over
Joe tidy Sky News in Farrington